In an era marked by religious decline,
Mormons appear to be holding their own.
One-quarter of Americans are religiously
unaffiliated today. Among young adults,
roughly 4 in 10 are now unaffiliated.
It's a trend that's affecting nearly
every major religious
denomination in the US,
with one important exception: the Church of
Jesus Christ of Latter-Day Saints.
The Mormon population in the US has
remained steady over the past few years,
even while other Christian
denominations have shed members.
So, why are Mormons faring so well?
It's all about family.
Mormons get married earlier,
stayed married longer, and have larger
families than members of other Christian
denominations. Mormons are also more
likely to marry within their faith than
members of most other religious traditions.
82% of married Mormons report
that their spouse is also Mormon.
For Mormons, family is really
fundamental. 81% of Mormons
prioritize being a good parent, and
nearly three-quarters say that having a
good marriage is one of their
most important life priorities.
Do you think the decline of religion in
the US is a good thing or bad thing?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds and be sure
to LIKE and subscribe
for more research and videos from AEI.